hi guys today we're going to be
examining the top eight characters from
my hero academia with multiple quirks
and if you disagree or agree with any of
the characters I've selected or think
I've missed anyone out please let me
know and I'm going to be doing more my
hero videos in the future pretty much
like this so please subscribe if you
enjoyed this video - spoiler warning for
the manga in eighth place on this list
we have the future number one hero and
central protagonist of the story is Zuko
midoriya otherwise known by his hero
name of deku deku possesses the quirks
known as one for all black whip and five
currently unknown quirks but he never
developed a quirk as a child dec whose
first quirk was one for all which was
given to him by ol Mike who decided that
Dec who was a worthy successor one for
all grants him the combined strength of
all the previous eight people who've had
the power before him specifically it's a
stock power piling quirk which enables
the user to continually build on top of
their own power for example imagine you
went to the gym for two months took a
break for three years came back to the
gym and was benching the same way
that's essentially what stockpiling is
you're always building on top of what
you've already built one floor also has
a second quirk which is the ability to
be transferred hence why unlike every
other copy scene in the show it has been
continually passed down through
generations to generation growing
stronger each time this transfer ability
was a quirk in itself and combined with
the stock power piling ability to make
one for all therefore one for yourself
is essentially two quotes combined thank
you second quirk or technically third
quirk is black whip and it allows the
user to produce black vines from their
arms the primary purpose of which seems
to be capturing people or objects if
they can chose to you could use black
whip to attack his enemies capture them
or throw projectiles at them it's a
pretty versatile work and very strong in
its own right black whip and five
additional unknown quacks like doormen
inside the core of one for all they all
belong to previous users of the power
but the manga implies that decking was
the first user of one for all who's been
able to harness the powers of previous
users if we were talking purely about
raw strength then deck whose combined
quirks would be in the top three of this
list but when you look at the bigger
picture he said himself that he's not
yet strong enough to use black whip
reliably and we have literally no idea
what the other five quirks are so given
that this is a list of characters with
multiple quirks I feel his additional
quirks don't yet do enough to go higher
though when Deku has the power to
harness black whip properly and we get a
good look at the other five quirks I'm
fairly confident that he will be right
near the top of this list
at number 7 on the list we have NATO
monomer in his quark which is known as
copy monomer is another first-year
student at UA and his power allows him
to temporarily copy the quirk of anyone
he touches monomer can copy multiple
quirks at the same time as switched
between them or will this makes him
incredibly dangerous however he can't
use them simultaneously the reason i've
included him on this list of characters
with multiple quirks is pretty simple
modem has vast improvements to his power
during only his first year have
convinced me that by the time he leaves
you a his power will be in a different
league in his first year he was able to
increase the amount of quirks he could
copy at a time from 3 to 5 that's an
increase of 66 percent furthermore he
doubled the amount of time he can hold
quarks from five minutes to ten minutes
given what we've seen recently in the
manga with the awakenings of characters
like sugar aki and toga i have no doubt
that if Moe number continues on this
current path it wouldn't be crazy to say
for example that he could retain three
quotes permanently and be able to use
them simultaneously he's an incredibly
determined individual and I think the
nature of his quirks gives itself to
having multiple quirks I'm pretty sure
down the line you will see him retaining
part quarks permanently a sixth place on
this list we have him eco toga a member
of the League of villains and basically
an all-round psychopath her base quark
allows her to transform into other
people but in the manga it was recently
revealed that the Power has evolved into
something more with her transformed
quark toga is able to physically
transform into anyone including their
clothes and vocal cords so long as she
consumes their blood first the duration
of her transformation depends on the
amount of blood she's consumed with one
cup of blood being equivalent to about a
full day of being transformed so what is
her second quark well as I explained she
has the ability to look like another
person but spoiler alert our quark is
now awakened and she can now in fact
replicate someone else's quark as well
this was shown when she copied Oh
chuckles zero gravity quark and used it
to deal with a group of antagonists by
lifting them up into the air and
subsequently hurtling them down to the
ground killing them and because of this
new copying ability which is so
different from the transformation I have
to say that in essence toga does have
two distinctive and powerful quirks at
number five is shadow Todoroki Shoto is
one of the most popular characters in
the series and his quirk is called half
called half hot it is the perfect fusion
of his father's flame quark which is
called hell flame and his mother's ice
quark with disability the right side of
his body can produce incredible amounts
of ice which can be used in a variety of
different ways
for example he can create waves of ice
protective barriers or even use the ice
to surf one he can use the power to
freeze things on a large scale or freeze
things quite precisely for example
someone's leg when we were first
introduced to his character sure to
exclusively used the icy side of his
body however things have changed a lot
since then and Shoto now utilizes the
left side of his body which has it
arguably even deadly a power on his left
side Shoto can release devastating
flames which as we seen recently in the
manga can be nearly enough to melt steel
Todoroki is very lucky in the sense that
both his quotes complement each other
incredibly well if his body starts to
heat up he can use the ice side to cool
him down and vice versa
this way he counteracts the dangerous
effects in a way his father never could
I think it's fairly obvious why I
consider this to be two quarks both
stand as quirks in their own right and
are very powerful the fact that show too
has both is a very lucky and rare
occurrence in fourth place is a
character that we've only seen in the
manga so far so if you want to skip to
third place right now you can just click
the timestamp in the description if you
want to avoid spoilers so at fourth
place is a character known as the high
end no move if you're watching this
video then you probably already know
this but noemi's are former human beings
who've been genetically modified into
basically disgusting monsters that can
hold multiple quirks the higher know me
though was special and it demonstrates
intelligence previously unseen by any no
moon and it has at least five
overpowered quirks that were able to
severely ruin and nearly defeat the
number one hero endeavor firstly it has
super regeneration which as we saw
enables it to regenerate from even the
tiniest part so long as even a part of
the head remains intact high ends entire
body can be regenerated from that single
part secondly he has a storage quirk
that allows it to store other
lower-level new moves inside his own
body during his fight with endeavor we
saw it released nine memories out into
the public
high-end also has mounted shoulder Jets
to allow him to fly and muscle
augmentation which allows to alter the
muscle fibers in his own body to
increase the power
iron can also shape-shift its arms an
example this occurred when it turned his
arms into wings and potentially maybe
you could shape-shift other parts of his
body
we only saw it shape-shift his arms but
we don't know what the potential of that
quirk is there are several characters in
the world of my hero academia whose
quirks are basically the ability of a
particular creature in the world sort of
like spider-man how he can climb on
walls we've seen floppy gang Walker and
supported seal to name a few all of
their quirks but just the persona
vacation of animal ability so at third
place on the list we have Tamaki amagiri
and his quark manifest manifest allows
him the potential to utilize all of
these animal quotes at once the manifest
quark allows the user to transform their
body to gain the characteristics of
anything the user has eaten so long as
it remains active in their digestive
system for example if he eats a clam he
can turn his hand into a dense clam
shell if he eats an octopus he can shoot
long tentacles out of his fingers this
quirk is basically every animal quark
you could want rolled into one but in
addition to that as we've seen in the
manga he can't consume non-food items
and manifest that as well the only
example we seen of this so far is
crystals taking out three professional
villains in the process
this makes the possibilities of his
quark basically endless manifest is sort
of like a parent quark that allows the
manifestation of several different child
quarks in practice it is more than one
quark overall there's a reason Tamaki is
in the big three at UA and there's a
reason he's in the top three of this
list as well at number two on this list
we have kaiju sake otherwise known by
his villain name of overhaul in my
opinion overhaul has two distinctive
quirks which I'm going to call
disassemble and reassemble though in the
manga they are both referred to by the
name of overhaul much like how Todoroki
and Deku squawks are referred to as one
name despite them inherently being two
powers with the disassembled quark
cheese aki can destroy anything he
touches we saw this for the first time
when he obliterated mr. converses arm
into a million pieces just by laying a
single hand on it this by itself is one
of the most powerful quirks in the world
of MHA but it is entirely separate from
his ability to reassemble things when
you disassemble something you take it
apart just because you can do this
doesn't automatically mean that you have
the ability to fix it as well luckily
for Chiaki he also has the ability to
reassemble which like Todoroki is the
opposite of his first quark but
complements it in a brilliant way by
combining these two quirks
she's aki can restore destroyed things
back to their original state for example
when used on a person overall could heal
any injuries or illness that they have
by reconstructing them to a biologically
perfect state he can cure his own wounds
literally during a battle if he wants
the guy is an absolute monster
furthermore the combination of these
quotes allows him to combine different
objects into a single entity including
biological things he can literally fuse
himself with others or fuse others
together with a single touch this quirk
has limitless
and if he can't get a handle someone
they're basically dead I believe he is
one of the few people who can actually
go toe-to-toe with the number one guard
lessness but yeah if you disagree in my
logical let me know but in my opinion
this is distinctly two quotes
disassembling things and reassembling
things are literally the opposite of
each other so the fact you can do both
is two quirks with that said the number
one villain on this list of characters
with multiple quirks is obviously all
for one who possesses a quirk of the
same name
if we're talking about potential all for
one is probably the best quirk in the
history of MHA the user is able to steal
other people's quotes by touching them
and either use them for himself or
transfer them to someone else that by
itself is literally three quotes think
about it you firstly have the ability to
rob someone their quote then you have
the additional ability by actually being
able to use that quote for yourself and
then you have the ability to give it to
anyone else you choose so right from my
offset this guy is overpowered that's
three quirk straight off the bat we've
seen in the manga that all for one was
able to make many allies due to the
nature of this power in a flashback we
saw him removing quotes from people who
didn't want them and giving those quotes
to people who work work lists this
allowed him to essentially build an army
a villainous Empire which has been
around for generations the additional
quotes that we have seen him demonstrate
which are obviously therefore stolen
quirks include longevity warping force
quirk activation infrared rays and such
now breaking this down longevity is a
quote that has allowed all for one to
exist for decades upon decades if I had
to guess I would say that he's at least
120 years old but despite that he has a
body of a young man but the less said
about his face the better the warping
ability allows him to what people to
inform his location but it can only be
used on people with whom he has a
relationship forced quark activation is
a favorite quirk of Wolfe ones he can
turn his fingers into black jagged
spikes that can stab into someone and
forcefully activate their quote against
their will but a lot of the time he just
uses it as a weapon additionally because
alpha one is blind he uses infrared rays
to see obviously this level of Parrish
ridiculous as he can combine all the
different quotes and use them
simultaneously to basically use powers
that would never occur naturally we saw
this during his fight with all my where
his arm turned into some sort of
disgusting monstrosity that would never
be seen in the world of mha without a
power like this so the fact that he can
take quirks combine those quirks give
them away at will
it basically makes him but ultimate bad
guy and pretty much unstoppable unless
your name is all might but yeah guys
that was the list of the top eight
characters in Maya academia who have
multiple quirks this is the end of the
video and I encourage you if you agree
or disagree with any of my selections
please let me know in the comment
section below like I said this is a new
channel so every single comment like
subscription it means a lot please like
the video if you had a good time with it
and subscribe because I'm gonna be doing
more videos like this
I started from mystery 0 subscribers at
the time of recording this I have about
12 so I'd appreciate if you could
subscribe and support the channel and
yeah thank you very much for watching
and if you're interested I've done two
previous chapter reviews of my ear
academia so you can check those out on
my channel as well